LLaASSTTT wEek I asked you guys to make a green screen competition. I recorded myself. Look at this =(...
How can you not be creative with this?-_- (10/10) Oh boy I can't wait to see all the submissions. Oh look, there are none!
You're all a bunch of crybabies (no u)
I think I have the fan base on YouTube consisting more and more and mostly of just a bunch of whiny sons of guns (getting that ad rev eh)
I can't swear and it pisses me off whatever. You know what I dOn't cArE. Let's just lEt's just jump into it
*gibberish stuff* - (YOU MEAN ARTT)
In Finland, we have a button to thank the bus driver when leaving. (0o0)
No, that can't be real. No honestly, it's not real, right?
''I am not prepared to wield such power.'' What happens if you don't press it? I have so many questions
Are they located all across the bus or is it in a spot where the bus driver will see it?
How does it signal the bus driver?? Does it play a little thank-you song? [maybe, i think not]
I need to know more information Finland, please provide more information
*clap clap* Congratulations Finland for doing something. (Now that's what this is all about!)
I didn't know it was possible. I thought Finland
was just one of those countries that never did anything ever, Dr. Phil *THE MAN HIMSELFF*
What is LWIAY and why do people keep asking me to host it? Let's *Clap* get *Clap*
Dr. Phil *CLAPP* to host *Clap* LWIAY! come on guys if this video hits 500 billion likes then [But how!?!]
then Dr Phil has agreed with me to perform on a concert may 25th
It's gonna be the biggest celebrity concert! for real guys. Everyone tweet. Dr. Phil, that would be 𝕖𝕡𝕚𝕔
I made him angry *Gasp*
We have ascended to phase two. You have too much power for any single man getting on the LWIAY this many times in the row
Getting- why do you guys keep thumbing up this shi-. don't make me swear just stop. I'm putting an end to this [you almost said s**t]
What is this baccckground even? everything about this annoys me. Okay, just stop forgive me for I have sinned. I seen this one it's so...ahAAHAaaA
Come on, it's good. Can I show this meme? what's the pewdiepie version of this?
That's what I want to see. y'all know what to do 😤
pp down
*random gibberish*
Never
What the hell does it say!? Stop putting secret messages in my videos. Oh my god, that's so annoying. We did it
*CLaP cLaP Cla *
Very nice everybody a nice little departure gift for our guy Stefan Karl rest in peace. 😪
Alright, finally finALLy. We have some green-screen competition edit
Look at this.
[eats popcorn]
Wow I don't remember filming this
[dang this figh- where's pewds facecam? tf]
[this is a great anime, now this is 𝕖𝕡𝕚𝕔!]
[pewds doing that hype he cool] "You just got tROLLED LIBTARD" REEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
DaAYMM, he's fast
IS THAT THAN0S CAR? (You belong to the brotherhood of the virgins, this meme must be strike down)
*Screeching continues* REEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
*EHHAHAEUAHA*
That's great, thank you canles Turns out you guys aren't completely useless. How about that give yourself a pat on the back
That's amazing. New! pewdiepie fortnite emotes, okay
You just got trolled, Libtard! *Hittin that shoot *CLaP cLaP* 😤
Yeah! (𝕖𝕡𝕚𝕔 big style, baby)
Looks like you just got trolled 𝕖𝕡𝕚𝕔 SYTLE! *10/10 Music*
Oh no I'm scared about the last one
Someone please kill me, I don't wanna be here I want nothing to do with this
*that mircosoft paper cilp sent you a error on windows xp*
pls end me life for the lov for god endi it
[what will happen next?]
*iT'S BACK* REEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEheeee
Can we add *cLAP* PEWDIEPIE *ClaP* to  for*cLaP*tanite?
500 million likes if we can make it happen. I set modest goals on this channel. Don't worry about it. That's great
Actuallydavide very nice 👌 (So you think you're better than me. Oh, yeah)
Bring it on
FahhhAAAAAA *Amazing power thank you*
YA
Your cancer meme can't penetrate my defenses *The most amazing dancing would watch again*
Don't hit the bomb Felix, good job. Oh my god (I will spare no thots)
*Random sounds?( Really starting to question my existence rip)*
Hi-yah I've mastered the art of the swordsmanship
*edgy moves now commence*
Incredible edit Wow, I'm so impressed. "Nothing will stand in the way of me and my virginity"
KACHOOO HOO ASIABFNDAAA *aka more random sounds rip*
Oh hello green pewdiepie
This probably takes so much time as well Aheehhehehe
Actually live footage from the Brighton Pier everybody. This was not green-screen
MY girlfriend told me she will marry me if I get 2k comments on this post
police help guys 🚔
Please guys help me marry my girlfriend by commenting on this video guys. guys. So this video gets 20 *Some for of wheeze?*
I mean, I do the same thing *Glad you're self aware*
I don't really. A moderator turned off commenting for this post dESSTruction A huNDrEd some people
Just want to watch the world burn
Martyr (mODERATEOR?) actually saved the guy's life. I can relate a joke!! a joke
Everybody. Alright moving on
RTX off
RTX on
God dayemm! God damn Pikachu looks sexy is it just me or is Pikachu looking very attractive? *OoOoo the italinoa hands*
Holy moly. Misty's looking very, very sexy and look at Ash. Look at Ash Ketchum *GOTTA KETCHUM ALLL*
Brock Obama... (O_O)
Did i say Brock Obama
*Wheezing(?) continues*
Dr. Phil dark, man now I'm just gonna laugh at anything
I mean, it's not you laugh you lose so it doesn't matter. Come on. This is a good meme
I like this meme template. Start a family find a prestigious job
Be happy upvote this image to die instantly, thumbs up this video to die instantly everybody
Can we hit Mass Geni  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) No ok No, okay, when a body part falls asleep
That's pretty accurate. That's pretty accurate. Right there. Humanity didn't ask for this level of accuracy. Why is that, huh?
Can we get a Vsauce 20 minute video explaining this phenomena, that would be great. Outfits that give you PTSD
Okay. Yeah, I know. I can't wear the stupid kitty things anymore, people just won't shut up in the comments
You should have added the beard to this outfit. I love those kitty things
Can I bring them back? (#BringKittyEarsBack2k18)When you think you're going to be the top meme of
September then the weebs started doing something bad to some gender swap dragon
Bongo cat still has a good chance. What do you guys think? Come on Bongo? Just bonGO ;D away. This is so sad
Can we mm... it's the only way it's the only way we can save bongo cat
When your meme always get eight upvotes so you decide to make a meme about your memes getting eight upvotes all the time
But you still get eight upvotes W H A C K and it gets 14,000
14,000
14,000 upvotes everybody. This is all it takes to be part of the Pewdiepie submission subreddit
Everyone submit your meme today guys new intro for meme review.
Oh Damn this looks legit
Oh, oh Oh oH, OH!
Ok but this is   E P I C   gUYS jacksfilms is quaking
Is it gonna say, is it really, the mad lad? !Oh my
GaaaAaAHHH *cLAps yet again*
DaYUMn dayummM
iT'S TiMe To StOp
It's time to start is what he said. damn alright official intro huh Alexa
don't play anything cuz it'll get copy strike. Yeah, that's right
I have actually had videos getting copy strike because Alexa starts playing like a two second ---ing clip YouTube 2018
It's you know, what don't go off on a tangent right now Felix. That's amazing. Thank you. Baromen. I'll use it next video
Honestly, the most professional, looking one. End this once and for all P Series, Pew Hub *I SECOND THAT*
excellent *CLAPSAGAINA*
Guys, I'm announcing a new website. I think you guys are really gonna like it. Fact cats have nine lives
This is nine, apparently. Felix need to make nine meme reviews about Bongo cat to kill it *clAP ClaP*
All right, that's another one. You're down to seven caticit?. That's English, apparently. Remember these?
Can this video get 1 million dislike. Can this video hit a million likes. Can this video get-
I mean what else could I possibly do? He could do, Can my pinned comment
Get 1 million likes. Okay Bros! This is epic. Okay. Alright challenge accepted. This is so sad
I used to play a lot of tennis. nine-year-olds. Let's get Pewds to *cPALS* play *clasps*tennis
You know what? I actually also played golf ANDI used to be a sailing instructor
That's right. I'm a man of many talents since you guys are nine year olds you'll like this story
I used to be a sailing instructor for a bunch of kids right a bunch of nine-year-olds and at the beginning of the lessons a-a-a-a
Everyone was like. C-Can I sail with Felix
I want to sail with Felix and then at the end of the week because we had a super stormy week and we ke- katp- kept
Capsizing because these stupid children doesn't know how to sail for some for some reason
And then at the end of the week, it was like who wants to sail with Felix? and everyone was like   ......
It was awkward moment ever like no one liked me. I'm a great instructor
Okay, these stupid children didn't- Stupid nine-year-olds. I hate th-  *There he goes again*
manga/anime
Netflix adaptation TEEE-series adaptation
TEe-Series, I'll use my special move against t-series  GAHSHSHHSAAA
Watching meme review in front of the European Parliament
God, damn this is savage
Excellent job. Mr. Hirosensei2 - good job *proud of u*
Everyone a round of applause for hirosensei2 - that's it for this week's LIWAYYY *More claps*
Youtube's favorite show everybody if you enjoyed this video smash like and subscribe if you haven't already
Submit a meme give it a go. Give it a try
It doesn't seem to matter what I tell you guys to do you'll just do whatever you want
Anyway, so just do what you do. Um, this is not a big deal or whatever. I'm having some problem with my videos
I don't know if it's a technical issue or whatever
I'm trying to sort it out with YouTube, but it seems like they're not publishing properly
I know it's such an old meme but they're not publishing properly to sub boxes. I
subscribe to my own channel, so I know it's not working properly because I'm not getting notified myself
And I don't know it's just a bunch of annoying stuff that you have to deal with behind the scenes
that can be really stressful and annoying but I notice a lot of really nice supportive comments in the last two videos and it really
Cheered me up when I was really annoyed. So I just want to say I appreciate you guys <3
always being so
Supportive. I know it's like a meme or whatever that I'm so annoyed all the time
but I see you guys and I appreciate you and I wanted you to know that so thank you very much and (we love you too)
I'll see you tomorrow. Goodbye  *NOOO WHERES THE OUTRO* *cries in anime*